[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
منذ عام
1030 وهذه العائله تعمل في صناعه السفن
التقليديه في ولايه الصور في سلطنه عمان
حيث تتوارث الاجيال هذه المهنه التي تشتهر
بها السلطنه لا سيما في المناطق الساحليه
[موسيقى]
المهنه هذه ورثناها احنا ابن عنجد
تقريبا احنا نكون اخر جيل ماسكين المهني
خلاص المصانع اول كانت اكثر من نصنع الحين
اخر مصنع سلطنه عمان يمكن في الخليج اخر
مصنع
صناعات خشبيه او يدويه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن هنا في اكبر هيكل لسفينه تقليديه في
سلطنه عمان هذه السفينه بدا العمل عليها
بدايات عام 2020 ومن المتوقع ان يتم
الانتهاء منها في اواخر العام المقبل
تكلفه هذه السفينه حوالي مليون دولار
امريكي
[موسيقى]
فوق
تقريبا من 50 الى 55 متر
نوعيه الاخشاب اللي موجوده
اغلى انواع السائق او اغلى انواع
[موسيقى]
متوفره كانت من افريقيا
هذه المهنه تواجه الكثير من التحديات
ابرزها انتشار السفن المصنوعه من مواد
الحديثه مثل الفايبر جلاس بالاضافه الى
عزوف الشباب العمانيه عن هذه الصناعه
والله شيء يعور القلب يعني احنا الصناعات
التي ربينا عليه حرام
من الحكومه الاساسيه
[موسيقى]
يضم هذا المصنع ورشه متخصصه بصناعه التحف
والمشغولات الخشبيه بالاضافه الى صاله
لعرض النماذج المصغره للسفن بكافه احجامها
وانواعها عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه
الصور العربيه
[موسيقى]